three meals 30 minutes and three dollars
or less because everyone is feeling the
pinch hey
hey sharp welcome to
[Music]
welcome
let me pop in here to tell you about my
sponsor today skins and I'm so excited
about this partnership because I've
honestly been wearing skims exclusively
for about a year and I recently got a
new haul from the fits everybody
collection and like hands down I will
wear nothing else their bras and panties
are so light and soft and comfortable
and they're designed to mold to your
body I wear them under like jackets or
tanks when I'm going out and exclusively
wear them to bed because again they're
just so breathable and light and skins
is really an industry leader when it
comes to size inclusive options they're
really creating the next generation of
underwear for everybody with sizes
running from xss to 4X and styles to
suit different body types the fabric
also stretches about twice its size
without losing shape so even the
products that I've worn a million times
still look really great so if you guys
haven't tried skins yet yourself
definitely start with their fits
everybody collection I promise you you
will be looked there's a reason why they
have over a hundred thousand five star
reviews so click the link in my
description to check out the fits
everybody collection and other Perfect
Fit Essentials plus you can get free
shipping on orders over seventy five
dollars and after you place your order
let them know that I sent you by
selecting YouTube in the survey and
selecting Abby's Kitchen in the drop
down menu that follows it really really
helps when they know that I sent you
grocery costs these days are out of
control I think we can all agree that
the price is not right the price is
wrong and it's not just in your
head while food prices traditionally
increase one to two percent each year
they increased 11 from 2021 to 2022 and
there's a 5.9 percent predicted increase
this year coupled with Rising inflation
interest rate hikes and a tumultuous job
market everyone is stretched really thin
both with their money and also their
time that said we still need so your
girl hauled her ass to Walmart on a
mission to make three back to work and
school meals and a bonus bedtime dessert
slash snack each under 30 minutes for
less than three dollars per serving
because yeah I I can only live on Boxed
mac and cheese for so long pretty long
but only so long so let's start with
breakfast so I think probably you'd all
expect me to do oatmeal because it is
the ultimate fast cheap and cheerful
breakfast but I thought we'd do a little
Savory alternative so we're gonna do
this little shortcut shakshuka style
breakfast I'm putting the shukshuka in
quotations because some of you guys get
angry when I call it a shukshuka because
I'm taking a few kind of canned
Liberties calm the down
but it's Gonna Save Us money and it's
Gonna Save Us time so I don't
let's do it
all right we got some Great Value Extra
Virgin Olive Oil oh
a little bit of that
and I got a massive onion so I chopped
the whole thing and I'm gonna use half
of it now on half of it at uh dinner
time
can go in now I was on a mission not
only to save you guys money but also
save you guys time and there's probably
no culinary job I hate more than peeling
and mincing garlic so I'm not gonna lie
sometimes I like to buy the Jarred stuff
and you'll be happy to know that it was
literally cheaper for me to buy the
Jarred stuff from Walmart than it was to
buy them fresh I don't know if it was
just on sale or what but it just seemed
like a really good deal so I'm going to
add a little bit of that no smelly Nails
required next I've got some tomato paste
I bought the tomato paste with herbs and
spices you can just go with regular but
I feel like this is going to save us a
little extra time I don't go rummaging
through my cupboards and my pantry
trying to find a specific spice or like
a melange of spices it's already
flavored for you so it's done some of
the work ahead of time and it's the
exact same price as the regular
look at that we're gonna coat our onions
in the tomato paste next I'm throwing
down some cumin spices are like
millisecents per serving so they're
always a great deal some cayenne for a
little spice and heat salt and pepper oh
and it smells so good
now I like to add a little bit more veg
action here and one of the cheapest
vegetables in my grocery store right now
is zucchini I think it's usually pretty
inexpensive when it is in season because
it's like a bumper crop so when people
grow zucchini they grow way too much of
it so they really just want to get rid
of it so I've got two zucchinis here I
have already decided I chose the wrong
pan for this yes if I did uh we'll see
how she goes and this is one of my
little shortcuts here we've got canned
tomato sauce that way I don't have to
you know cook this down for hours and
let it simmer and like or like puree it
myself I've always got time for that and
anybody got time for this so I'm gonna
add in that canned tomato sauce
and again this is already seasoned right
so it's got your garlic powder onion
powder Paprika in there so it's adding
some of that flavor get it get it get it
get it get it and just as we are
reaching the top
capacity of this pan I'm gonna add a
little of the canned diced tomatoes
again I use uh the season so this one's
the Italian seasoning it's the same
price as the unseasoned so you might as
well get a little extra flavor in there
so I'm not going to put the juice I'm
just going to add some of the actual
chunks
extra flavor
okay I think that's as ambitious as it's
gonna get
because we still have to put eggs into
this Lord help me I know you guys are
watching from home being like yeah
that's not gonna work girl that's not
gonna work eggs going down xcc's are out
of control so I just went with your
basic cheap and cheerful large eggs
obviously if you want to spend a little
bit more you can get like the free range
or the omega-3 eggs Etc but these are
the ones on sale I'm gonna carefully do
this
oh we did get a little shell
out this outfit will definitely need to
be dry cleaned by the end of this a
little more salt a little pepper
all right just turn it down a little I'm
gonna carefully put a lid on just just
poach those
oh yeah looking good if you're dairy
free this is perfection all on its own
but I always like to top mine with a
little bit of crumbled feta just like
that and I slice up a multi-grain
baguette from the Walmart bakery this
whole meal here and clothing the bread
clocks in at 7.92 cents for the whole
recipe for four or a dollar ninety eight
per serving I'm pretty sure I've spent
like 22 dollars at brunch on the exact
same thing
it's an eggy
that is so good
all right for lunch let's do salad and
one of my favorite cheap proteins is
canned tuna but to stretch the even
further one thing I always like to do is
to add in some white beans so that way
you get some plant-based proteins and
some fish and it stretches your budget
out really well so let's do it so one of
the things I love to do with my salads
is to kind of make my own little
croutons and if your bread is at the end
of its life this is a great way to use
it up especially if your whole family
refuses to use the butts so we're going
to use the butts and all I'm going to do
is just rip this up obviously you can do
this in like a huge batch and then use
them for different purposes throughout
the week but I'm just going to show you
for one serving and I'm All About The
Ripping technique
I just have something really
and I am all about the ripping technique
because then you get all like crispy
bits all over the little corners and
Jagged edges all right a tiny bit of
olive oil just to crisp it up
and lots of salt
all right all right all right all right
I'm just going to throw this into a 450
degree oven while I prepare the rest all
right to the Bowl we got some red wine
vinegar olive oil oregano salt
pepper I'm being summoned I'll be right
back
coming then I got myself a head of leaf
lettuce it's definitely the cheapest
lettuce that I was able to find but she
needs a good cleaning so let's do that
lettuce down
I know we always complain that lettuce
is expensive and it normally is but I
think I got this whole huge head of
lettuce for under two bucks so can't
complain about that I'm gonna give that
a little drizzle of our vinaigrette
and the rest is going in here cucumber
again one of life's cheapest vegetables
you get a whole cucumber for less than
two bucks I've got some red onion here
these adorable little baby Tomatoes were
on sale so yes I definitely picked those
up add some nice color and I'm doing a
combination of the chunk light tuna and
some white cannellini beans because a
whole can of this stuff is a buck 50.
obviously make sure that you drain and
rinse very well give it a good toss
and let's plate her up all right
croutons done just in time for the salad
plating
yeah
like this is a big salad right
you guys thought I was just gonna make
like tiny salad portions making a big
mess I should have chose a better
platter like I'm really oh
I'm failing at the chores of serving
wear today this is hilarious okay guys
just give me a second and because we
clearly didn't have enough on our plate
I topped it all off with a little bit of
feta because it totally worked well with
the recipe and we already had it in the
fridge from breakfast this whole big
salad works out to eight dollars and 24
cents per recipe or two dollars and six
per serving and she looks satisfying
this is a full-on hunger crushing combo
Lots going on gotta get it all oh my
gosh I can't even it's making a mess
because says I put too much there's just
too much food here folks
hmm
oh my God I got that little homemade
crouton situation you're gonna be doing
that hack more often I swear okay
that's so cool all right for dinner
we're gonna do pasta it's such a cheap
and cheerful staple in my house we
always love pasta night so I'm gonna
throw down some of these shells in some
hot water and then we'll talk
I gotcha I got you there we go okay
we're starting this recipe off similar
to breakfast a little olive oil
probably should turn on the burner but
this time with a bigger pan because
I learned all right onion down that's
the second half of our onion from this
morning all right garlic going down all
right I'm gonna let that hang over hot
man I gotta check on my pasta give it a
stir I'm gonna take a good gulp of pasta
water pasta water retrieval
good Mission good Mission and for this
recipe I'm employing the same money
saving technique that I use with the
lunch where we did kind of a little bit
of tune-up and a lot of beans in this
case we're doing half a pound of ground
chicken and a whole can of black beans
and I actually compared the prices of
the ground chicken or ground turkey to
the ground beef I got this one on sale
so I was going for it but in most cases
you'll probably save a little bit more
if you do do beef so if your family eats
a lot of beef you can probably save a
little bit extra using that as well oh
Jesus
oh no let me cut that out
hot minute and drain our pasta all right
throwing down our black beans
drained and rinsed I got a packet here
of the reduced sodium taco seasoning and
again sometimes the healthier version is
more expensive but in this case it was
the exact same price as the regular
sodium so why not now normally I love
bell peppers with this recipe but the
price of bell peppers are out of control
unless you like green bell peppers in
which case you're a psychopath but
instead I opted To Go for Frozen
butternut squash it is super inexpensive
and it's so much more convenient than
buying it fresh because trying to cut a
bunch about squash it is like an
occupational hazard honestly you're just
asking to go to the ER so I'm just gonna
you know what why not add that fiber in
while that's heating through I'm going
to add some chili seasoned diced
tomatoes again you might as well get the
pre-flavored stuff
and finally this is where the starchy
cooking liquid will come in that's just
going to release
all the flavor from the taco seasoning
and make a nice little sauce
season her up let's get that pasta in
there
there's space come on
very carefully
move
finally I'm going to add in some frozen
corn
you can also do fresh if it's still in
season and while it's still warm we're
gonna hit it with some shredded cheese
I would appreciate it because yes you
pay a little bit of a premium but in my
books it's totally worth it to save the
time this recipe literally has it all we
got lots of fiber in all our veg protein
in the beans and the chicken carbs in
our pasta and some fats in our cheese
and look at this this worked out to 9.89
for the whole pan or 2.47 cents per
serving
yeah the cheese is key
all right finally unilo some sweet and I
have always really just been super into
graham crackers like from childhood to
today they're inexpensive they're easy
to find and they're naturally lower in
Sugar so this is actually a sweet snack
that I often make for myself and my kids
and you get a little bonus hunger crush
and combo action in there if you'd like
yes oh no searching
nothing fancy going on here folks but it
does taste really really good so I got
my graham crackers I just broke them
into squares so they're easier to eat I
got some peanut butter and honestly in
my Walmart there wasn't a huge
discrepancy between the natural peanut
butter and the kind of like Skippy style
peanut butter in terms of price so I
just went with the natural because
that's what I usually buy anyways a
little smear I feel like crunchy would
be extra delicious on this but my peanut
butter has to do double duty and my kids
need it smooth we got a banana here
which is obviously one of the most
inexpensive fruits year round but if you
are a banana hater because I know I get
a lot of banana haters in my comments
apples would be equally delicious and
because we're coming into fall they are
particularly inexpensive this year so a
little banana Boop
you gotta make a Boop for each one or it
doesn't count
okay done we only took half a banana for
all these and this is delicious just as
is but everything's better with a little
chocolate chip fraction right so a
couple little chocolate chips
for fun because banana chocolate and
peanut butter she just hits different we
got a little fiber Protein healthy fat
action going on and a whole lot of
deliciousness and it works out to 53
cents per serving
um
mmm it's so good
I love graham crackers I don't know I
feel so
fired here like I feel like the biggest
hesitation with a lot of these kind of
budget friendly recipes that I read
online is that they tend to take way too
much effort and time but under 30
minutes that I can do but if any of you
have any affordable and super fast
recipes that are in heavy rotation these
days in your home definitely leave a
comment below I'm sure we can all use
some extra inspiration also don't forget
to hit up my description for my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]